تم تقليص الكثير من الحريات
في أوكرانيا منذ أن بدأ الغزو واسع النطاق،
وحظر التجول، والتجنيد الإجباري والقيود الأخرى،
ولكن الآن قد
يحصل الأوكرانيون على الماريجوانا الطبية الجديدة من نوع Freedom،
والبرلمان الأوكراني يسير على الطريق الصحيح
لجعل الحشيش الطبي قانونيًا لعلاج
الجنود والمدنيين الجرحى الموجودين الآن هناك.
كانت هناك جهود لإضفاء الشرعية على الماريجوانا
قبل أن يكون آخرها قبل عامين
وفقًا لزعيم الأغلبية في مجلس النواب
في البرلمان الذي يقول إن المشرعين
يستجيبون للحقائق الجديدة التي
جلبتها الحرب، وترجع هذه الجهود جزئيًا إلى
مناشدات الجنود الجرحى أحدهم
الذين  يقول المشرعون الذين فقدوا ساقهم بسبب لغم أرضي
إن مسكنات الألم خففت من آلامه
ولكنها لم تخففها تمامًا وكان
لها آثار ضارة أخرى.
ويقول المشرعون إن الماريجوانا الطبية
يمكن استخدامها ليس فقط لعلاج
الألم المزمن ولكن أيضًا لعلاج قدامى المحاربين الذين يعانون من اضطراب ما بعد الصدمة والمدنيين الذين يعانون من اضطراب ما بعد الصدمة.
السرطان والأمراض الخطيرة الأخرى
الماريجوانا الترفيهية على الرغم من أنها ستظل
غير قانونية، فقد مر مشروع القانون
بقراءته الأولى في البرلمان
ولكنه يتطلب تصويتًا آخر قبل أن
يصبح قانونًا، لكن بعض المسؤولين المنفيين في شبه جزيرة القرم
يقترحون بالفعل أن
زراعة النبات للاستخدام الطبي يمكن أن
تكون جزءًا من التنمية الاقتصادية لشبه جزيرة القرم.  التعافي إذا
نجحت أوكرانيا في استعادتها